let's do
this right now we're in the studio for
some trolls 3 this is so fun whenever we
get the gang back together you can just
feel how much fun everybody has you're
so in I mean I get to plan my best
friend's wedding it's my wedding there's
a lot going on come on guys it's time we
are gathered here today to stop the
wedding un Branch's long lost brother
what you're the guy from brozone we were
just listening to them
baby Branch it's time we find the rest
of our brothers and get the band back
together operation family Harmony is on
and
popping I can't believe that is really
happening it's a wild ride the story has
so many different twists and turns oh my
gosh
hello my name is vaa Poppy I'm your
sister poppy loves family so the idea of
having a long lost sister is super
exciting did you just braid my hair you
welcome it looks so good I love it Viva
has a lot of energy and vitality inside
am I being a lot sometimes I can be a
lot you poppy sister oh wow it's just
like such an embarrassment of riches
when it comes to the
[Music]
cast oh this is too
much RS band together has more fun more
action more
music there's no better way to
experience this movie than on a big
screen cor me
D bye everybody we're getting the band
back
[Music]
together milkshakes to
celebrate is this how people feel when
they meet me
yes